people in Malawi were preparing for
another election after the
Constitutional Court nullified last
year's presidential vote saying it was
marred by widespread irregularities but
now they've been told there's going to
be an appeal at the Supreme Court on
21st May 20 19 went to an election at
which I'll declared the winner
at that time our local and international
observers agree that we had a peaceful
free fair and credible election xmw I
saw him dr. Rajesh chharia and dr. Saul
Simha petition that consider caught with
their grievances the may 20 19
presidential election results showed
Metallica beat this man opposition
candidate Lazarus Shakira by 159
thousand votes and lead of just over 3
percentage points
Shakira says he's not worried about the
appeal they have a right to do that if
they know they have a case but you
cannot really think you can succeed
against five judges who had a unanimous
decision the Constitutional Court judges
said several people may have voted more
than once there was evidence of ballot
stuffing and some figures were changed
using typewriter correction fluid it's
the first time a presidential election
has been challenged on legal grounds in
Malawi for months opposition supporters
protested over last year's disputed
election some people fear an appeal
could spark more demonstrations
opposition supporters have criticized
African and international election
observer missions for endorsing the
disputed polls a lot of what we saw for
the entire electoral process is what the
international observers saw except when
it came to management transmission of
results and the determination and
announcement of results the way of
things you know that people who come
from outside could not easily observe or
if they observe they can't quickly make
sense of what's happening because you
require to be grounded in the chords in
their practices and so you begin to put
things too
and you realize that in this case 2 plus
2 is not equal to 4 it is something much
more than for the outcome of the
president's appeal is likely to have
major implications for Malawi both
politically and economically harder
Matassa al Jazeera along way